how's it going everybody it's Warren and
not too long ago Disney announced that
they are coming out with their own
streaming service Disney Plus to compete
against all of the other streaming
services such as Netflix Hulu and all of
the others and upon announcement of
Disney Plus we got word that they would
be developing specific Marvel series for
Disney plus some series that are
confirmed are a vision and Scarlet Witch
series a Bucky and Falcon series and a
Loki series so fans were pretty excited
about the fact that we're going to get
these exclusive series but they were
even more excited when we found out that
Tom Hiddleston is actually going to come
back to reprise the role of Loki in this
series Disney CEO Bob Iger came out and
said we're also currently developing a
live-action Marvel series about Loki
starring Tom Hiddleston playing the
character he's made so famous and
everybody loves Tom Hiddleston as Loki
so fans were pretty excited but
according to a new rumor this might not
actually be the case the rumor comes
from that hashtag show and they say that
Tom Hiddleston will not actually appear
on screen but will in fact be narrating
the story of his life from hell
obviously fans are not too excited about
this but I wanted to address this
because this is just a rumor for right
now this has not been confirmed by
Disney or Marvel it's just a rumour
right now and could have very well been
started on purpose we're supposed to
think that Loki is dead right now and
obviously having Tom Hiddleston reprised
the same role of Loki that he played in
the MCU would raise some questions as to
how he's alive so spreading a rumor that
he's actually going to be just narrating
the story of his life from Hell could
just be to throw people off Marvel has a
lot going on right now they have a
vendor's endgame captain Marvel's
spider-man far from home the Disney Plus
coming out but the biggest thing that
they have going on right now is Avengers
endgame by far so they're going to do
everything they can to try and not spoil
the movie so it's not confirmed it's
just a rumor for now and I wanted to set
that straight because a lot of people
are really disappointed because they've
read or heard or watched something that
says that this is confirmed and how it's
going to be it's not it's just a
let's assume that he's still going to do
it but let me know your thoughts in the
comments down below do you think that it
would be interesting to have Tom
Hiddleston narrate past stories of his
life or would you like to see Tom
Hiddleston still play Loki and pick up
after the events of Avengers endgame let
me know your thoughts and I'm still
giving away a life-sized Infinity
Gauntlet if you'd like to enter for your
chance to win all you have to do is
subscribe to my channel like this video
and comment down below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero as
always thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof
[Music]